That actually does it for Unit 6.
We basically got to the main points that I wanted to tell you about.
I wanted to kind of express the notion of NP completeness and give you a chance
to play with that a little bit, and in the homework, we're going to look at that in a little bit more depth.
So I will give you more practice problems to think about.
In a smaller class, you would probably be writing proofs, but for this class,
you're going to write some programs and do some multiple choice questions.
So good luck on the homework, hang in there. We're almost done.
The next unit is just going to be interviews and a song that I put together for you,
and a kind of a summary of what we did in these units.
So thanks a lot for listening.